When you're coming to Target for one thing and it's in the back of the store,
it's actually a pretty long walk!
Oh yeah, got to get those. Oh, the candy hearts aren't even Star Wars  themed - that one says bling.
You know, exactly what you'd expect the stormtrooper to say.
Are there no peeps? I was expecting peeps. A little leopard.
Good morning, John. Good morning, John. It's time to get ill.
H: Red Velvet Oreos. That where we're going to start? Why you mess with Oreos? K: I know, like, it's the perfect cookie. Why would you?
I'm here for the cream cheese icing. I could eat these. H: All right, well, then you will. K: Gotta make that baby bigger.
H: This is the Reese's Pieces with the leo-pard. Oh, they're just peanut butter cups!
K: I am wild about them. That's going to end up in the background of Hanks videos, I bet.
H: Good chance. You don't want to review these? K: Save those for later. Well, I mean,
alright.
H: Oh yeah, they really know what they're doing with these. Alright, I wanna try this rose. Chocolate made in Belgium. K:. Oh, well, yeah.
Packed in China. Wow, this chocolate
has been everywhere. H: Oh, it's fa- it fell right off. I though I was going to, like, hold it out to your mouth and--
Well, it is Valentine's day, let's take a bite out of it together like we're Lady and the Tramp. K: No-
H: That is dangerous! K: Try one of these. H: I hate strawberry and chocolate, honestly. K: Maybe you'll be surprised.
I was surprised by the red velvet oreos.Two in here. Two. H: Oh my God. It's like a pop tart, but with chocolate.
K: I like strawberry pop-tarts. H: It's a good taste. K: Yeah? H: Kinda like a pop-tart with chocolate. K: See? H: So, this is the quintessential valentine's item.
K: Conversation heart. H: The quality control has gone right out the window. K: Yeah, like half of these don't even have anything on them.
*loud crack*
H: That's the noise that candy should make.
H: You wanna try this Nerd rope? H&K: Ohhhhh! K: We made different noises, but the same noise. H: Lady and the Traaaamp! K: God.
H: God, come on, baby.
K: It's unpleasant!
H: I love Nerds. I haven't had a Nerd in a long time. Cotton candy should only happen in one place, and I feel weird having purchased it at a store.
I like it though. K: It's good. H: Yeah. K: Very good.
K: Trolli sour hearts.These are a little troublingly sticky.
H: Ohhhh!
I like that. That was my favorite sugar based candy so far. K: Chocolate truffle kisses. H: Like, Hershey's kisses,
like, they were made this shape because they were just drops of chocolate, but now this has been manufactured to be this shape. (K: Yeah.)
so they can put something inside of it. K: Clue piece.
H: Totally, yeah. Like, a-- K: Professor Poop.
In the bathroom. H: What did he do it with, Katherine?
K: Toilet paper. H: Toile--Toilet paper murders!?
I'd say that's better than a regular kiss. K: Definitely.
H: And we're going to finish off with a Lick-a-Made Fun Dip Valentine mystery flavors!
K: I have to lick this stick first? H: You have to lick-- well, it's like, a candy. K: This like, weird, giant, pill?
H: I feel like they're just lying. They're like, "we didn't want to buy any flavoring for this batch,
so we're making it the mystery flavor." Yeah, by which we mean: sugar. K: Your brain will suggest a flavor.
H: Do you wanna try mine-- (K: In your mouth!) --because it feels like it looks the same. K: You want me to put my
licking stick into your licking hole?
H: Baby got cranky. K: Baby does not like candy.
H: I hope not. We don't usually celebrate Valentine's Day, you and me, but we did something this year: this. K: Hooray.
Yeah, I'm looking forward to my stomach ache. H: Thanks for comin' on the channel.
K: Yeah, happy Valentine's day.H: Happy Valentine's day. To all of you in platonic ways.
H: Also, if you're wondering, during the poster sale that we had last weekend we raised $71,000.
So $7,100
going to 10 different refugee resettlement organizations in America.
Thank you all so much. Thank you to all the artists. Thank you to everybody who helped put that together and everybody who bought something. You're great!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday. K: Bye!